after the Prometheus follow-up alien
covenant was released in 2017 rumors
regarding another sequel began
circulating online
despite whispers of cancellation there
is still a glimmer of hope for Ridley
Scott's next outing and the universe he
helped create four decades ago in 2012
prometheus was released to decent
reviews and was a modest financial
success accumulating four hundred three
million dollars worldwide in the film a
team of scientists and archaeologists
venture off to a distant moon found in
ancient star maps the expedition which
aims to find out more about the
engineers who came from the stars to
create humanity is met with strange
horrors that changed the nature of their
mission from discovery to survival
[Music]
five years later Ridley Scott would
return to direct alien covenant the
sequel to Prometheus in which a ship of
interstellar colonists makes a detour to
a planet that they speculate has a more
hospitable environment than their
original destination of course this
Haven is not what it appears and the
colonists find themselves in the realm
of the ever-evolving Xenomorphs while
Prometheus did well both critically and
financially alien covenant did not mixed
reviews Illustrated coming its inability
to pack as much of a punch as the
previous entry in the franchise likewise
the box office numbers didn't while 20th
Century Fox that ain't only two hundred
and forty million dollars worldwide
while the film wasn't without its
supporters it wasn't the kind of success
that leaves studios salivating for
another sequel following covenants
released further developments regarding
the future of the franchise were scarce
most likely because the film didn't
perform nearly as well as Fox had hoped
according to The Hollywood Reporter
covenants ticket sales dropped 71
percent during its second weekend and
Fox reportedly stated that to further
alien sequels which had been on the deck
would have to be quote reassessed rumors
began to circulate online about the
cancellation of the Covenant sequels
shortly after the movie hit theaters a
December 2017 report from the fansite a
VP galaxy cited a user on the blu-ray
comm forums who claims to have worked on
covenant and explained after the box
office results filming was cancelled and
a warehouse storage unit full of stuff
was auctioned off a few months ago so
the original plan of pumping out another
quickly
has definitely changed with no immediate
plans for anything though the validity
of the statement hasn't been confirmed
there are indications that the users
account has some truth to it and the
film was either cancelled or put on hold
I think it's safe to say that none of us
are too keen on getting back at one of
those pods before the release of alien
coming in Ridley Scott spoke with
Fandango saying if this is successful
and then the next one there will
definitely be three more this could mean
a projected total of six prequel films
before the events of the original alien
but only if covenant was a success
Fandango wasn't the only place Scott
showed his excitement for the future of
the alien series in an interview with
The Sydney Morning Herald he enthused if
you really want a franchise I can keep
cranking it for another six I'm not
going to close it down again no way
that's what I'm going is that is not the
plan because I'm really right I've heard
the next one is what if they don't know
to drive the point home he talked about
having written the next installment
saying you've got to assume to a certain
extent success and from that you'd
better be ready
of course regardless of Scotts readiness
it was soon apparent that covenant was
not going to be as successful as its
predecessor putting the future of the
series in question further complicating
the matter that Disney Foxx merger was
finalized in early 2019 reliable
information regarding the status of a
covenant sequel has been sparse but
recent reports imply Ridley Scott's is
still currently working on the project
while it's pretty unlikely we'll ever
get to see it the Covenant sequel does
have a title alien awakening it's set to
begin where covenant left off after
David put the survivors of the org I 6
into cryo sleep after that everything is
pretty much speculative according to The
Sydney Morning Herald Scott and
screenwriter John Logan developed the
awakening script while covenant was in
production Empire seemed to confirm this
with an article that shared supposed
plot details according to the magazine
the engineers hunt down David and his
xenomorph embryos as they head off to
lv-426
the planet were the crew of the Nostromo
land and find the xenomorph eggs at the
beginning of the original alien however
according to Scotts chat with Fandango
awakening would bring the series full
circle with the film taking place
between Prometheus and covenant the
director explained there will be another
one before we kind of literal
logically clockwise back into the rear
back head of the original alien whether
that time line represents a
contradiction of Empires plot summary or
was a simple slip of the tongue is hard
to say a six minute short film titled
Advent which was featured as extra
content on the alien covenant blu-ray
may hold some clues as to what we could
look forward to of awakening ever
happens the film serves as an epilogue
to the events of covenant and sees David
send a transmission to the
weyland-yutani corporation explaining
his reasoning for creating the xenomorph
I come to you with an olefrog
you may know me you certainly know of my
Creator basically David wants to create
a queen that will be able to breed new
xenomorph thus allowing the species to
continue without his intervention
awakening will still take place before
the first alien film and like the other
prequels in the franchise will likely
explain the lore surrounding the
Xenomorphs and scientific excursions
have proceeded those an alien
considering the information Advent
provides about David's motive it's
unlikely that awakening will continue to
showcase David's dark experiments at the
end of the short David ominously touches
the tube that is housing Daniel's while
he talks about his hopes of creating the
Queen the implication is that Daniels is
likely going to serve as some pawn and
David's scheme but exactly what role she
will play remains to be seen based on
what we know from the beginning of alien
it appears as though Michael
Fassbender's David will have a hand in
bringing the Xenomorphs to lv-426
fortunately for Ridley Scott Fassbender
has stated that he would be more than
happy to continue with his role in
future installments in May of 2019
Fassbender was asked if he would be open
to reprise in his Android character once
more and yet I love I love the character
it's a lot of fun so yeah I definitely
enjoy he isn't the only actor who has
expressed interest in returning to the
alien series Kathryn Waterston is also
eager to reprise her role as Daniels in
an interview with The Playlist Waterston
said I would be absolutely game to do
more if they wanted to have me
considering that Daniels is the last
character to interact with David and
covenant and the short film Advent hence
said she has a more significant role to
play in his plan it's almost certain
that Waterston would be called back to
reprise her role of awakening
has passed the writing stage however
Waterston is expressed that she is
relatively in the dark regarding the
film status according to the actress
I'm always usually the last person to
know even what's going on in my own
career so I'm probably not the best
person to ask but I did get some sense
of where they thought they might like to
take it when we were shooting covenant
and it sounded really interesting check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]